[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann guten antrag von mir und
das sind die themen von heute
putins forderung im erdgas streit ab
morgen soll der westen ruwe konnten bei
russischen banken eröffnen berlin pocht
auf zahlungen in euro
angst vor getreide man wegen des kriegs
in der ukraine beraten deutschlands
agrarminister über eine höhere
produktion
und weltrekord im frauenfußball mehr als
91.000 fans sehen den clásico zwischen
dem fc barcelona und real madrid in der
champions league
wer als westlicher käufer russisches gas
haben will muss ab morgen 1 rubel konto
bei der gazprombank einrichten sonst
wird nichts mehr geliefert das hat der
russische präsident heute per dekret
verfügt ob das für die deutschen
unternehmen viel ändert ist fraglich die
bundesregierung ist sich mit frankreich
großbritannien und italien einig die
firmen zahlen vertragsgemäß weiter in
euro weniger hat mehr
politik in paralleluniversen in moskau
die präsident putin am nachmittag an die
öffentlichkeit und teilt mit was er
gerade entschieden hat gras ab freitag
nur noch gegen rubel
um an gas zu gelangen müssten
ausländische kunden rubel konnten bei
der gazprombank eröffnen erklärt putin
wenn diese zahlungen nicht erfolgen
werden wir das als vertragsbruch werden
mit allen nötigen konsequenzen der
bundeskanzler hat zeitgleich besuch aus
österreich gestern erst hatte scholz mit
putin telefoniert dabei soll der
russische präsident ihm dargelegt haben
dass zahlungen weiterhin in euro
geleistet werden könnten
nach einer reuters meldung hat herr
putin gerade gesagt ab morgen muss in
rubel bezahlt werden könnten sie bitte
noch mal sagen was jetzt ihre
befürchtungen sind wir haben die
verträge angeschaut über die
gaslieferung und die anderen lieferung
daran steht drin dass ein euro gezahlt
wird manchmal dollar ab in der regel in
euro und ich habe in dem gespräch mit
dem zwischen präsidenten klar gemacht
dass das auch so bleiben wird und wie
seine vorstellungen sind dass das
geschehen kann
das ist das was wir jetzt genau
anschauen werden aber auf alle fälle
gilt für die unternehmen dass sie in
euro zahlen wollen können und werden
bislang läuft das gasgeschäft mit
russland so ab gazprom liefert gas an
deutsche energieversorger die
bezahlenden euro an die gazprombank die
bank ist bislang nicht sanktioniert
unklar ist wie sich putins erlass ab
morgen auswirkt ob die staaten in euro
bezahlen aber zudem ein weiteres konto
eröffnen müssten auf dass ihr geld in
rubel konvertiert wird
wichtig ist für uns dass wir nicht das
signal geben wir lassen uns von putin
erpressen und was sie dann mit dem geld
machen ist solange die banken nicht
sanktionen unterliegen weitesgehend ihr
bier das machtspiel rund um die
gasimporte geht also weiter euro oder
rubel
fragen wir valerie haller an der börse
wie kann dieses geschäft funktionieren
und welchen vorteil hätte putin davon
also darüber rätselt die gesamte
finanzwelt aber sie jetzt mal wie es
funktionieren soll nach dem was wir
wissen über weiß der deutsche
energieversorger künftig in einem ersten
schritt euro oder dollar auf ein konto
bei der gazprombank die wiederum tauscht
es in rubel um und überweist es an
gazprom nach russland unterm strich
dürfte sich also für deutsche
unternehmen nicht viel ändern ihre
rechnungen begleichen sie nach wie vor
in euro oder dollar wie die westlichen
regierungen es auch wollen was dahinter
steckt ist nicht ganz klar könnte sein
dass putin damit den rubel wenigstens
psychologisch stärken will also vor der
eigenen bevölkerung demonstrieren möchte
dass der rubel eine gefragte währung ist
vielleicht aber ist das auch nicht viel
mehr als ein politisches muskelspiel
nach dem motto der westen tanzt nach
meiner pfeife ökonomisch jedenfalls
scheint der rubel umtausch aus jetziger
sicht für russland wenig sinn zu machen
wichtige informationen aus frankfurt am
main valerie haller das vielen dank
valerie
vor zwei tagen hatte russland
angekündigt seine truppen aus teilen der
ukraine zurückzuziehen als zitat
vertrauensbildende maßnahme nach
einschätzung der nato ist das kein
rückzug sondern eine neue formation um
die offensive im osten des landes zu
verstärken
zugleich halte russland den druck auf
kiew und andere städte hoch sagt
nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg er rechnet mit zusätzlichen
angriffen und noch mehr leid christoph
distel und jürgen kehl über die aktuelle
lage
klinische bilder vom gezielten
eingriffen so inszeniert der kreml
weiter seine militäroperationen durch
den anderen den brutalen krieg kann auch
moskau kaum noch kaschieren
vor allem im nordosten erobern
ukrainische truppen gerade städte von
den besatzern zurück kamerateams gehen
hinterher filmen wie hier nördlich von
kiew das grauen in fast unwirklichen
momenten auf patrouille am waldrand
vorbei an getöteten russischen soldaten
feinde täter einer der ihre gesichter
gesehen hat schüttelt den kopf
all diese leichen das sind nur kinder
kanonenfutter dass ihr in den krieg
geschickt wurde
und das ohne klaren plan da ist sich der
britische geheimdienst inzwischen sicher
wir haben berichte über russische
soldaten die sich demoralisierte und
fast ohne waffen weigern befehle
auszuführen ihre eigene ausrüstung
sabotieren und sogar aus versehen ein
eigenes flugzeug abschießen
auch die stadt trotz tja netz konnten
die besatzer nicht halten
überall niedergebrannte häuser aber kein
mensch auf der straße so beschreiben
ukrainische soldaten den moment der
befreiung erst langsam hätten die
bewohner verstanden sein dann aus ihren
kellern gekommen an den monate unter
besatzung erinnern sie sich so
die russen führen sich auf wie tiere es
war ihm völlig egal ob kinder oder
ältere menschen sie plünderten und sie
töteten ein augenzeugenbericht im
kriegschaos aber so der ähnlich gehen
viele auch diese aussah borussia im
süden
schwer verletzt erzählt eine frau im
krankenhaus was in ihrem dorf unter der
russischen besatzung passiert ist sie
haben sich um ihrer mutter gesorgt
ich gehe mit erhobenen händen zu ihrem
haus und sagte dem soldaten dort dass
man mir schon erlaubt habe zu passieren
aber er feuerte aus seinem
maschinengewehr und traf mich überall
von der hüfte an abwärts
auch in mariupol der katastrophen start
dieses kriegs wird alles eher noch
schlimmer kaum essen kaum wasser hieß es
schon vor wochen es bleibt dabei nur
dass gerade die letzten kräfte ausgehen
170.000 eingeschlossene warten auf hilfe
der ersehnte konvoi ist wohl auch heute
nicht durchgekommen
dieser krieg hat viele opfer er
vertreibt nicht nur ukrainer und
ukrainerinnen aus ihrer heimat auch aus
russland flüchten menschen zum beispiel
in die ehemalige sowjetrepublik georgien
seit kriegsbeginn sind es nach
georgischen medien mehr als 40.000 sie
sind gegen putin gegen den krieg oder
sie haben einfach angst zum
militärdienst eingezogen zu werden in
georgien hoffen sie auf ein neues leben
christiansen berichtet das ist erst mal
ihr neues zuhause ein zelt in einer
wohnung in tiflis michael und seine frau
lisa sind froh dass sie überhaupt so
schnell eine wohnung in der georgischen
hauptstadt gefunden haben hauptsache weg
aus russland
als putin den krieg begann haben wir
begriffen dass wir nicht mehr zögern
dürfen dass ein neuer eiserner vorhang
droht und dass es bald keine möglichkeit
mehr geben wird zu einer legalen
ausreise
der 25 jährige ingenieur hatte angst
dass russland das kriegsrecht ausruft
und er zum militärdienst eingezogen wird
das fürchten alle russen im wehrfähigen
alter die hierher kommen denn wer sich
den militärdienst widersetzt dem droht
gefängnis
ich gehöre zur it-branche es heißt leute
aus der it-branche werden nicht
einberufen vielleicht hätte mir nichts
gedroht aber ich kann das nicht
einschätzen
georgien sehnsuchtsort für touristen
jetzt zufluchtsort für russen die lage
zwischen russland und georgien ist seit
jahren an gespannt weil auch georgien
richtung westen strebt den krieg gegen
russland 2008 haben sie hier nicht
vergessen
wir sind ein gastfreundliches volk aber
wenn die russen hier schlechte ziele und
absichten haben können wir genauso
schlecht antworten
michael und lisa wollen hier jetzt fuß
fassen die wohnung schön machen einen
job finden ein neues leben beginnen
zurück nach russland das kommt für sie
erst mal nicht in frage
immer aktuelle informationen zum ukraine
krieg haben wir in unserer app im live
blog finden sie einschätzungen von
korrespondenten und experten den stand
der dinge in der ukraine und
auswirkungen auf deutschland
russland und die ukraine zählten bislang
zu den größten weizen produzenten jetzt
wächst die sorge des weizen in ärmeren
ländern knapp werden könnte in
deutschland sprachen die agrarminister
deshalb darüber wo hier mehr angebaut
werden kann eine möglichkeit wären die
sogenannten ökologischen
vorrangflächen größere betriebe dürfen
fünf prozent ihrer fläche nicht nutzen
der umwelt zuliebe
170 tausend hektar liegen deshalb brach
eine fläche zweimal so groß wie berlin
andreas weise berichtet ein acker unweit
von zörbig in sachsen-anhalt derzeit
haben die bauern hier vor allem wieder
trockenheit zu kämpfen könnten sich aber
trotzdem vorstellen kurzfristig mehr
anzubauen beim ihrem betrieb zu einer
circa so 130 hektar die wir einfach
nicht nutzen und davon könnte man
vielleicht 50 hektar einfach mal noch
mit mais bestellen
250 euro pro hektar gibt es von der eu
wenn fünf prozent der gesamtfläche brach
liegen bleiben eine langfristige
klimaschutzmaßnahme jetzt auch brüssel
kurzfristig diese flächen mit zu
beackern auch wenn deutschland derzeit
keine engpässe drohen der getreide
weltmarkt ist mächtig unter druck wenn
man sieht dass aus der ukraine und aus
russland in den nächsten monaten keine
ernten für europa und für den rest der
welt vor allen dingen zu erwarten werden
dann müssen wir hier auch ein beitrag
leisten und der beitrag muss sein auch
darüber zu diskutieren und das werden
wir hier machen dass man die
brachflächen auch zur futtermittel und
nahrungsmittelproduktion nutzen kann in
deutschland die agrarminister der länder
und des bundes diskutieren heute und
morgen unter leitungen sachsen anhalts
vor allem darüber der bund will anders
als die eu die brachflächen nur für
futtermittel freigeben selbst das ist
für naturschützer schwer zu verdauen das
ist eine maßnahme für dieses jahr das
ist ja auch wegen der dürre zeiten in
den letzten jahren immer mal wieder
erlaubt worden das ist gerade vielleicht
noch verschmerzbar aber wichtig ist dass
wir ab 2023 weiterhin zu den vier
prozent wirklich nicht bewirtschafteten
ökologischen flächen in der
agrarlandschaft stehen dann vor allem
die ukraine wieder normal liefern kann
ist unklar gerungen wird jetzt um
kurzfristige lösungen
am arbeitsmarkt hinterlassen krieg und
die hohen energiepreise noch keine
spuren dank der üblichen
frühjahrsbelebung gegen die zahl der
erwerbslosen im märz sogar zurück zwei
millionen
362.000 menschen waren ohne job
66.000 weniger als im februar
die quote liegt jetzt bei 5,1 prozent im
vergleich zum märz des vorjahres sind es
465.000 arbeitslose weniger
jetzt corona das
gesundheitsministerium plant offenbar
die quarantäne für infizierte und
kontaktpersonen auf fünf tage zu
verkürzen
außerdem könnten die strenge isolierung
aufgehoben werden der vorschlag soll
nächste woche mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder
abgestimmt werden jetzt der blick auf
die zahlen das robert-koch-institut hat
innerhalb eines tages
274 1901 neuinfektionen registriert
43 1486 weniger als vergangenen
donnerstag
279 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
dazu die sieben tage incidents sinkt auf
1.600
25,1 zu viele überstunden und
wochenenddienste aus protest dagegen
beteiligten sich ärztinnen und ärzte an
kommunalen krankenhäusern an einem
warnstreik
zur zentralen kundgebung in frankfurt
kamen nach gewerkschaftsangaben 4000
menschen die klinikärzte fordern 5,5
prozent mehr gehalt an den betroffenen
krankenhäusern von heute keine planbaren
operationen statt notdienste worden aber
eingerichtet
die bundesregierung hat zehn deutsche
mutmaßliche us anhängerinnen und ihre 27
kinder aus gefangenenlagern in syrien
zurückgeholt sechs von ihnen wurden
direkt nach ihrer landung verhaftet
gegen die anderen wird ermittelt ihnen
wird unter anderem vorgeworfen sich der
terror miliz in syrien angeschlossen zu
haben
afghanistan ist etwas aus dem blick
geraten dabei braucht das land dringend
hilfe die vereinten nationen wollen
heute auf einer geberkonferenz
milliarden sammeln trotz aller kritik am
regime der taliban das beschneidet vor
allem die rechte der frauen immer
rigoroser andreas stamm
kaum zu übersehen die taliban sind
wieder an der macht sei das gesicht
nicht zu sehen die zweifache mutter ist
in kandahar bei der familie ihres mannes
untergekommen der nach iran fliehen
musste seitdem kein lebenszeichen ohne
ihn gilt zu wenig zum leben zu viel zum
sterben
meine kinder sind krank ich habe kein
geld für medizin ich sammle flaschen auf
der straße verdienen damit 35 cent am
tag das reicht nicht für mehl öl oder
reis um über die runden zu kommen in
kandahar der taliban-hochburg gibt es
immerhin noch einiges doch kaum jemand
hat arbeit wo sollen die leute denn das
geld zum einkaufen hernehmen klagen die
händler die wirtschaft am boden
hilfsgelder teils blockiert zehn
millionen kinder bräuchten dringend
unterstützung wie die menschen erreichen
ohne dass das geld bei den taliban
landet an diesen spagat versucht sich
die virtuelle un geberkonferenz mit
organisiert von der bundesregierung das
ziel vier milliarden euro einsammeln
die weltgemeinschaft muss geben damit
die afghanische wirtschaft atmen kann
und die afghanen essen können reiche
mächtige staaten können nicht ignorieren
welche auswirkungen ihre entscheidungen
auf die ärmsten haben der erste schritte
einer humanitären reaktion muss bedeuten
die spirale des todes der wirtschaft
aufzuhalten
acht monate seit der westen das land
fluchtartig verlassen hat neue krisen
haben die welt seitdem verändert nicht
aber afghanistan das ohne hilfe tiefer
im chaos und armut versinken dürfte
zurück nach deutschland hier hatte vor
einem halben jahr der musiker gil ofarim
mit antisemitismus-vorwürfen großes
aufsehen ausgelöst jetzt erhebt die
staatsanwaltschaft leipzig anklage gegen
den 39 jährigen wegen falscher
verdächtigung und verleumdung in einem
video hatte vor ihm erzählt einem
hotelmitarbeiter in leipzig hätte ihn
aufgefordert seine kette mit dem
davidstern abzunehmen und ihn beim
check-in benachteiligt die
staatsanwaltschaft ist überzeugt so wie
es oben geschildert hat kann es nicht
gewesen sein
jetzt zum fußball frauen champions
league norbert war gestern abend
endstation für bayern münchen ja ein
königsklassen krimi im viertelfinal
rückspiel gegen paris st germain münchen
hat ja das hinspiel 1 2 verloren in
paris stand dann nach 90 minuten 2 2 1
für die bayern in der verlängerung
schaffte psg den ausgleich und das
weiterkommen bayern trainer jens scheuer
kann seinen pariser kollegen ollé
nicolle erhobenen hauptes gratulieren
denn obwohl sein team sechs corona
bedingte ausfälle und diesen kuriosesten
frühen gegentreffer durch baltimore zu
beklagen hat liefert es paris einen
großartigen kampf nur zwei minuten
später nach kopfball ja schülers der
ausgleich durch die japanerin kuba geil
nach dem wechsel sogar die 2 1-führung
klarer bühl egalisiert mit ihrem
abgefälschten schuss die 1 2
hinspielniederlage
es geht also in die verlängerung und in
der schießt dann die eingewechselte
schweizerin bachmann die bayern aus der
champions league
ins halbfinale
und beim clasico der frauen zwischen dem
fc barcelona und real madrid gab es
gestern abend einen weltrekord noch nie
hatte ein fußballspiel bei den frauen so
viel publikum 91
1553 fans sahen im stadion kam noch das
viertelfinal rückspiel titelverteidiger
barca gewann mit 5 2 und steht im
halbfinale der champions in
katar hat heute der fifa-kongress
begonnen weltverbands-präsident
infantino rudert bei seinem plan zurück
die wm alle zwei statt bisher alle vier
jahre abzutragen und kündigt die
kandidatur für seine dritte amtszeit an
business as usual auf dem treffen der
funktionäre fußball first bei themen
abseits des rasens vermeidet der
präsident die klare stellungnahme keine
missbilligung des russischen vorgehens
in der ukraine und auch keine kritik an
den arbeitsbedingungen derer die in
katar die wm infrastruktur errichten
fußball im mittelpunkt die deutschen
fans schauen auf die auslosung das dfb
team nur in topf 2 auf deutschland
hatten kontrahenten aus diesem topf
unter den möglichen gegnern also unter
anderem spanien und frankreich morgen ab
18 uhr wissen wir wer die gruppengegner
der deutschen sein werden dem treffen
der funktionäre in doha blieben
ukrainische vertreter übrigens fern auch
dazu vom fifa präsidenten kein kommentar
das was im sport engagiert beim wetter
hat der norden deutschlands heute früh
schon mal abbekommen was den rest noch
erwartet der winter schneit noch mal
rein bis zu zehn zentimeter lagen zum
beispiel in hamburg klar im vorteil wer
die mützen und den schlitten noch nicht
eingemottet hat
wie das ganze weitergeht verrät ihnen
gleich es denn terry im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn spricht marietta slomka
mit wladimir klitschko
ehemalige boxweltmeister und bruder des
käfer bürgermeisters danke für ihr
interesse alles gute in und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gut und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter in den nächsten stunden müssen
sie mit noch mehr schnee rechnen denn
das schneetief ihr rutschte allmählich
weiter in den süden und vor allem in der
mitte und morgen dann auch im süden
weitere schneefälle geschuldet ist dass
der ganzen tatsache dass die eisige luft
aus dem norden zu uns kommt hier der
jetstream in orange zu sehen es stark
wind band in zehn kilometern höhe das
begrenzt diese kaltluft und ist relativ
stabil wir schauen in die nacht jesus
schraffiert ist müssen sie mit einer
schneedecke rechnen oder überfrierende
nässe also es wird glatt auf den straßen
nach norden ist es aufgelockert
teilweise im süden regnet es bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus zwei
grad in der mitte und +5 grad zb in
bayern morgen dann weitere schneefälle
in der mitte vor allem in den
mittelgebirgen und im süden geht der
regen allmählich auch in schnee über im
norden merkt man wenig davon scheint die
sonne bei höchsten temperaturen von
minus ein bis plus acht grad und am
samstag da schneit es vor allem im süden
noch an den alpen und lästern
allmählichen tagesverlauf nach
temperaturen am samstag - 1 bis 9 grad
ein schulamt